el jefe del pentágono y secretario de
defensa de eeuu el general lloyd austin
visitó este domingo israel es la primera
visita oficial de un alto cargo
estadounidense lo hizo con un mensaje de
compromiso hacia el que su principal
aliado en medio oriente
durante nuestra reunión le reafirme al
ministro gans que nuestro compromiso con
israel es duradero y firme me he
comprometido a continuar con nuestra
relación estrecha y he querido
garantizar que israel va a mantener su
ventaja cualitativa militar así como
fortalecer su seguridad
austin se reunión con el ministro de
defensa en funciones benny ganz los
políticos dieron una rueda de prensa
conjunta en israel existe preocupación
por el acercamiento de eeuu a irán su
principal enemigo para recuperar el
acuerdo nuclear de 2015 abandonado por
donald trump en 2018 israel se opone por
el temor de que irán pueda desarrollar
armas nucleares a largo plazo para
gamefest este criterio austin
enfaticé al secretario austin que israel
ve a estados unidos como un socio pleno
en todas las amenazas operacionales
cabe destacar irán el teherán de hoy
posee una amenaza estratégica para la
seguridad internacional en todo el medio
oriente y para el estado de israel su
red
y la política exterior de la
administración de joe biden está virando
israel e irán se están acusando de
sabotajes y ataques en siria además eeuu
recuperó la ayuda de cooperación con
palestina son gestos que no han gustado
en ciertos sectores conservadores de
israel provocando que yo y austin haya
tenido que enviar un mensaje de
tranquilidad